Okay, hi.
So, yesterday I was chatting on Skype with a friend from New York.
And I know there's a lot of differences in...
Every country has their own language...
...and even like, English-speaking languages have their own takes...
...on particular words and phrases.
When it comes to cars,...
...you pop the hood.
We don't call it a hood.
We call it a bonnet.
And we don't pop the trunk at the back.
We don't call it a trunk.
We call it a boot.
You go to the gas station.
We go to the service station, which is odd...
...because people don't really get their cars serviced there anymore anyway.
You go to the grocery store.
We go to the supermarket.
You walk down the sidewalk, we walk down the footpath.
You park in a parking lot, we park in a car park.
You wear a sweater, we call it a jumper.
You call it a soda, we call it soft drink.
Oh, and then there's shopping cart, which we call a trolley.
Oh, there are so many!
Oh, and what you call a cookie, we call a biscuit.
And that's even more confusing...
...because what you call a biscuit is what we call a scone,...
...except we don't pronounce it "scone".
We pronounce it "scone".